today I'm going to talk about a natural
remedy that can act as a homemade Viagra
and so all you have to do is drink one a
glass of this per day and I think you're
going to be pleasantly surprised what's
going to happen and so our topic today
is erectile dysfunction
the biggest problem that I see with
erectile dysfunction is men go to the
doctor they get diagnosed and then they
get treated there's really no
understanding of what's really behind
this condition other than you're getting
older and everyone has this and you know
you're just going to have to manage the
condition what's interesting about
erectile dysfunction is that many times
if not most of the time
the hormones are normal when you test
them and many times men with erectile
dysfunction have a high incidence of
high blood pressure obesity diabetes
they're smokers and when someone is
prescribed a medication like Viagra and
about 30 of the time it doesn't work and
many times there are side effects like
getting gangrene of the penis now that
might be rare but it does happen and if
someone has that side effect and they
have to remove the penis that would be a
very severe side effect so in this video
I want to discuss what's really behind
erectile dysfunction the penis is the
barometer of something called
endothelial Health now what does
endothelial mean it's a single layer of
cells
on the inside of your arteries and veins
and even the lymphatic system and
erectile dysfunction is one of the
earliest signs of peripheral artery
disease now when we talk about
peripheral arteries we're talking about
the arteries in the peripheral part of
your body the legs and the arms and
there's additional Clues to know that
you have this problem but you have to
realize fifty percent of the time there
are basically no symptoms but as this
problem progresses you may notice cold
feet
painful legs cramping in the lower legs
you may notice color changes in your
lower legs like your ankles you see this
in diabetes a lot you might even see
like a a bluish tint or red rash or
extra pigment of the lower part of the
leg you may notice that wounds tend to
not heal as fast you may notice a loss
of hair on your lower legs these are all
symptoms of peripheral artery disease or
at least early indicators that there's a
problem so having erectile dysfunction
is not really a problem of the penis it
is a problem with something more
extensive now the penis is a very
sensitive hydraulic organ now what does
hydraulic mean well there's something
involving
a higher amounts of pressure and in this
case we're talking about blood pressure
in a smaller space to allow movement of
something and so when someone has an
erection they have several things
happening that involve these Hydraulics
they have an inhibition of the
sympathetic nervous system that's the
flight or fight mechanism that's like
the stress part of the nervous system so
under stress uh you're not going to get
an erection now at the same time you're
also getting an increase of the
parasympathetic nervous system and this
is the system that helps you relax helps
you recover and so the parasympathetic
also primarily dominates digestion and
sleeping this could also explain why
some men can get an erection in the
middle of the night okay but not during
the day and also with an erection you
have an increased blood flow and then
you also have something called increase
nitric oxide nitric oxide increases uh
the blood flow Vaso dilation and it
allows you to actually achieve an
erection and the same things that affect
peripheral artery disease affects this
nitric oxide and this would be age high
blood pressure diabetes being overweight
stress now there's another enzyme that
you know it's probably not important to
know but it's just the mechanics of how
Viagra works and it's an enzyme called
pde2 in cell Viagra inhibits that enzyme
now your endothelial layer
how can you heal that and allow that
part of your vascular system to function
to be able to restore an erection well
it's a matter of fixing the real cause
underlying this problem but in the
meantime there's several things you can
do to at least improve this situation
probably the biggest reason for this
problem is a person has insulin
resistance because they're on the wrong
diet and so if you really want to
correct this insulin problem okay which
is present in pre-diabetes and diabetes
and even before diabetes and it's also
present in high blood pressure as well
as obesity you need to get on the
ketogenic diet for sure but in the
meantime there are several things that
you can do in combination in a drink
that can help increase this nitric oxide
now there's an amino acid precursor for
nitric oxide called citrulline okay and
the food that has the highest amount of
citrulline happens to be watermelon
that's right watermelon the thing about
watermelon is high in sugar too so if
you are in a strict ketogenic diet what
you can do is you can juice the Rind
part including the white part of that
rind okay and let someone else eat the
the sweeter part but we're only going to
be recommending one cup of this juice so
it's not going to be terribly high in
sugar so citrulline will increase nitric
oxide it'll also decrease ammonia which
is good but there's two other things
that can increase nitric oxide naturally
the most potent thing is beets okay beet
root now if you don't want to juice the
beetroot you can get powder you can get
bee powder I would recommend organic
bead powder and you can mix two
teaspoons of that in this mixture I'm
probably going to have to add like eight
ounces of water with it but if you have
a juicer it might as well just get a
medium sized beet and juice it okay with
a cup of watermelon juice okay make sure
you juice the Rind and all but again if
you're on the strict ketogenic diet just
discard the red part now have you ever
read on the back of the label with
sausages or bacon and it says there are
nitrates in there okay and sometimes I
have an uh a source of nitrates that
come from a natural substance and that
would be celery root so in other words
celery is very high in nitrates and so
you can juice about a cup of celery
juice in this mixture there are other
things you can add to this or substitute
and that would be any of the dark leafy
greens like arugula kale and even
spinach I wouldn't recommend spinach if
you have a tendency to get kidney stones
because they're high in oxalates but for
some people they can do it just fine but
all of the dark leafy greens are loaded
with nitrates so you want to drink one
glass of this every morning for a period
of you know four to six weeks the next
thing you want to do if you're doing
this is to stop all porn okay there's a
condition called porn induced erectile
dysfunction out of all the things that
can cause erectile dysfunction porn is
probably at the top of the list because
it really artificially messes up the
whole biochemical process by looking at
pictures and it's just very unnatural
you're going to over stimulate you're
gonna deplete your dopamine reserves and
it can lead to a very strong addiction
and create a lot of additional health
problems another thing to do would be
nose breathing I did a whole video on
this when you breathe through your nose
like when you're exercising maybe not
all the time but if you try to focus on
nose breathing you'll have more nitric
oxide you actually have more oxygen too
in the body and of course the last thing
is exercise because exercise also
increases nitric oxide all right so now
that you know that I think the most
important thing now is to understand
more about this nose breathing technique
and for that information I put the this
video up right here